ce que je veux dire par là c'est que de
cultiver les passions tristes de la
france c'est tout à fait possible la
france a été très profondément
antisémite la france a dénoncé il ya eu
des centaines de milliers de lettres de
dénonciation pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et la france elle est capable
d'autre chose elle est capable de ça et
elle est capable de faire de se
redresser comme elle l'a fait à la
sortie de la guerre c'est à dire
d'inventer le service public d'inventer
les peaux les avancées sociales qu'elle
a fait d'intégrer tout le monde est ce
que je vais dire ce que c'est pour ça
que je pense que contrairement à vous je
crois que le discours
ça construit le peuple qu'est ce qu'on
raconte sur quoi on se met d'accord
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire ensemble et
aujourd'hui moi je veux bien qu'on
constate qu' il ya des gens qui ont peur
des immigrés que iso ils veulent plus de
flics et cetera et cetera moins ce que
je dis c'est que ce avec ça nous allons
vers une un déchirement de notre société
et en plus en plus que c'est un
déchirement notre société je pense ça ne
nous permet pas de nous préparer à
l'avenir c'est à dire le réchauffement
climatique l'eau montée des inégalités
la question de préparer la
transformation de la france pour le
nouveau siècle etc tout ça c'est à côté
du sujet on pourra toujours changer les
prénoms des enfants à la naissance ça ne
fera aucune solution pour ces enjeux
majeurs
[Musique]